Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah, and
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, do the right thing. Post the
video or click the link below and donate
for your own akhera.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing?
Dr. Mohammad Marandi is an individual
who's come on Piers Morgan's show many
times. He's an excellent spokesperson
and analyst, actually a professor
at the University of Tehran.
Uh and an individual who's been a
pro-Palestine supporter from the very
beginning.
Uh I came across this particular
exchange between uh Marandi and Piers
Morgan. I want to watch it with you and
then come back and respond in kind. And
you advocate the devil. It sounds like a
guy who is trying to dictate to women
how they should dress, how they should
behave. They don't understand that in
the West we look at that as
reprehensible behavior.
No, in the West you objectify women, you
commodify women, and you sexualize
women, and you have Epsteins and many
Epsteins who control
>> give women the freedom to dress how they
wish?
Why would you
Why would you decline them that freedom?
No, we In Iran we have women pilots, we
have women scientists. My boss at the
University of Tehran, the dean of my
faculty is a woman. For the 21 years
that I've been an academic at the
University of Tehran, 17 and a half of
those years the dean of my faculty was
one woman or another. Don't misrepresent
Iran. It doesn't work anymore, Piers.
Your Western empire is on the decline.
The whole of the global South is
witnessing the crimes that are being
carried out by your regimes and your
declining regimes are now despised by
your own people. You're crushing people,
students who are protesting genocide.
You're not even crushing students who
are protesting your own government for
something that they're doing at home.
You're crushing students for protesting
genocide in another country, but you
can't tolerate that and your media is
controlled by a bunch of a group of rich
people. They control the narrative and
you call that a democracy. Your choice
is either Hillary Clinton or
Biden or Trump and then when that
decision is made, the whole of Europe,
Canada, the UK, Australia, New Zealand
fall in line as good soldiers. You don't
have democracy. Now, I love the way that
Dr. Morandi was able to kind of
get to the crux of it really quickly
with Morgan and repudiate, rebuke his
claims because quite frankly, Piers
Morgan was coming across as a very
imperial colonialist
manner talking about Iran, a country
he's never visited, a country he doesn't
know much about, he doesn't know the
language of, he doesn't know the culture
very well, but he's speaking about it
with authority because the propaganda
that he's been fed about that country
has skewed his judgment.
Now, putting that to the side for now,
the claims that Mr. Morgan was making
about the West, here in the West we do
such and such. Now, first of all, the
West is not some kind of monolithic
entity, okay? The West includes the
United States of America, even the
United States itself can be looked at in
different ways depending on where you
are United States. Then you've got
obviously Western Europe and Western
Europe is very different. France is very
different to the UK, the UK is very
different to Germany and the rural areas
are very different to the urban areas.
So, there is some kind of
differentiation one must make from a
sociological perspective when talking
about this West that you're talking
about. The second thing is this,
it's actually demonstrably false what
Mr. Morgan was saying. When he was
saying that here in the West women can
wear whatever they want. It's not
actually true that in the West women can
wear whatever they want. If a woman
walks naked into the streets, she will
be arrested in many of the if not most
of the Western countries. If a woman
wears a bikini into a secondary school
in the United Kingdom, she might not be
arrested, but she will be told to go
home. And she may even be reported on
the news because that is something seen
at the very least to be unusual behavior
and probably by British people to be a
provocative thing to do for a woman to
do in front of secondary school boys,
let's say year 9, year 10, year 11 boys.
It wouldn't be accepted in any of the
secondary schools in this country. So,
this idea
that either legalistically or
institutionally a woman can wear
whatever she wants in the West is
demonstrably false. There are cultural
constraints, there are legal constraints
constraints, and there are institutional
constraints. A woman can wear a bikini
in a beach, that's culturally acceptable
in the West, but if she wears a bikini
in a bank, that's culturally
unacceptable in the West. And that is a
form of constriction. Now, it might be
surprising for Mr. Morgan to know that
there is no prescribed Islamic
punishment
for a woman not wearing the hijab in the
Quran or Sunnah. It's something
surprising for you to know maybe that
actually
um she cannot be forced to wear a
headscarf or something like that by a
stranger man or by the police or
something. She cannot be forced in that
manner. There is nothing that I have
read, and I have studied this subject
formally, there is nothing that I have
read
in any of the what you refer to as Abwab
al-Fiqh or the chapters of jurisprudence
Islamic which indicates that there is a
rigid punishment or a prescribed
punishment or something that the Prophet
Muhammad said or something that is
mentioned in the Quran relating to a
punishment for a woman not wearing a
headscarf. Now, of course,
just like the West, there are going to
be constraints as to what a woman can
wear. If a woman wears
nothing in the streets in the Muslim
country, there may be action taken
against her, but that's not something
which the Sharia spells out in any black
and white sense. So, people have to use
their common sense just like they do in
the West in the Muslim countries as to
the extent to which a man or a woman
uh can display uh certain aspects of
themselves, certain uh genitalia or
otherwise in public. That's the first
point. So, this misnomer that in the
West you can do what you want and in the
East, you know, this is all constrained
and this is an authoritarian regime and
all these kind of things
is false. Uh Mr. Moradi, or sorry, I
should say Dr. Moradi
was able to justify for some of the
things and he he was able to say, "Look,
you know, I had a boss that was um
Iranian a woman and she had this many
women who got pilots that are women,
we've got this much representation of
women." That's That's a good thing for
him to mention. Which shows that
inherently he's not against the fact
that women are in the workplace and
Muslims are not inherently against women
working. This is a misnomer of Islamic
uh religious teachings. Okay, there are
some aspects of man or woman going into
the workplace or woman that's got a
child or something which obviously the
motherhood aspect is emphasized above
and beyond working for a woman. And I've
got a whole seminar on Western feminism
actually which you can access on this
channel.
Uh 2-hour seminar where uh you know, I
deconstruct the patriarchy, the ideas of
the patriarchy. Um I deconstruct uh
aspects of feminism which a lot of
Western commentators when they're
authorizing or otherwise orientalizing
or otherwise looking at
the Orient, the or the East in a certain
way, they use a colonial feministic
paradigm to do so.
Actually, when they do so
they first have to justify why they
believe in feminism. Why is that the
truth?
And when we've seen as an example the
paradox of female happiness as a
sociological phenomena which shows that
despite increased rights after 1960s,
after second wave feministic uh
activism, uh women have actually
increased in their depression, in their
sadness in the West. Don't tell me this
is a woman's, you know, freedom and that
the West is some kind of bastion and
some kind of a utopia and some kind of
an ideal place, okay, for Western women.
Western women have their own struggles,
psychological, pathological,
sociological studies
and struggles which are different, are
differentiated markedly and sometimes
worse in many ways than the most
impoverished and disenfranchised women
you'll find in Africa, Asia or
elsewhere. So, this misnomer needs to be
uh rectified. So, I I really like the
fact that Dr. Marandi was able to show
um that actually the
this is coming off the back of the
Epstein
the Epstein scandal, essentially,
showing that this is part of Western
culture, frankly. You guys, in your
Western your elites, they indulge in
eating children, they indulge in
um
raping children, they indulge in
uh sexual assault against people,
prostitution, by the way, and this is I
read in this excellent book that I also
recommended in the seminar by Louise
Perry called the A Case Against the
Sexual Revolution,
that actually the these aspects of
sexualizing women, which Dr. Marandi was
uh speaking about,
they actually they actually are in the
interest of men more so that they are in
the interest of women.
And in the first chapter of her book,
she mentions Hugh Hefner, actually, is
an interesting parallel now with the
whole Epstein situation because the
Epstein
revelation is the is Hugh Hefner on
steroids. And you cannot say that that
level of sexual promiscuity and um
permissiveness leads to a sociological
net positive result for women in the
West. And this is the case that she's a
reactionary feminist Louise Perry makes
in her book. So, that's one aspect of
things. The second thing is so, you got
Epstein, it's part of your culture to
exploit women. It's actually partly in a
way that's different, markedly different
from any other culture in the world,
especially with your elites. You're not
in a position to be morally
grandstanding and morally in a
sanctimonious sense,
you know, speaking down at all of these
other cultures. Piers Morgan, you should
have learned your lesson a long time
ago.
Um and you have to educate yourself on
these things because it just comes
across as colonial. I'm happy the way
that Dr. Marandi dealt with it. Um and
that's what I have to say. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
You probably don't deserve to watch this
video. Your level is honestly too low to
watch this video. So, feel free to click
away from the video. But, for the few
who can handle responsibility, we're
building the only masjid in a village in
Norway. First payment is already done.
Final 500,000 remaining. Huge sadaqah
jariyah awaiting. If you're serious
about Islam, you'll pause the video and
you'll click the link below to donate
right now. If not, enjoy the comment
section.